you
Darren's to Brora Otsu present era Nobel
Prize targeting literature tengo el gran
or the presentar el premio novel the
literature ah it is a great honor to
introduce the Nobel laureate in
literature mr. Mario Vargas Llosa
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen I
am a storyteller
so before I propose a toast I will tell
you a story once upon a time there was a
boy who learned to read at the age of
five
this changed his life
oh into the adventure tales he read he
discovered a way to escape from the poo
house the poor country and the poor
reality in which he lives and to
germinate wonderful mesmerizing places
people with the most beautiful beans and
the most of pricing things where every
day and every night brought a more
intense more thrilling more unusual form
of bliss he so enjoyed reading stories
that one day this boy who was now a
young man took to making them up himself
and writing them he had a hard time
doing it but it brought him pleasure and
she delighted in writing tales tales as
much as he delighted in reading them the
character in my story
however was very aware that the real
world was one thing and a de fancy world
of dreams and literature quite another
and the delight that only came to light
when he read and wrote stories the rest
of the time it vanished until one day in
the wee hours of the morning the
protagonist of my story
receive a mysterious call in which a
gentleman with a name that defying the
defied all pronunciation announced to
him
he had won a prize and that in order to
receive it he would have to travel to a
place called Stockholm the capital of a
land known as Sweden or something of the
sort to his total Pig will Merlin my
karate then started to experience in
real life one of those stories that
until them he had only found in the
unreal an ideal realm of literature he
suddenly felt like the popper mask I
felt when he was confused with the
premise in the Mark Twain's The Prince
and the pauper he is still there quite a
start left not knowing whether he is
dreaming or fully awake whether what is
happening is for real or alive whether
what is occurring his life or literature
because the border that separates the
two seems to have totally vanishes
dear friends now I can propose the toast
I had promised let us toast to Sweden
that a strange Kingdom that seems to
have performed today for a privileged
view the miracle of Turin life into
literature and literature into life
Cheers
skal muchas gracias
you